It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢忙得不可开交，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Are you dreaming about your next vacation? If so, you're not alone. For many Americans, travel is increasingly viewed not as a luxury, but as a necessity. According to Investipedia's 2025 American Dream Study, 75% of millennials consider annual vacations a key part of their version of the American dream, even more than traditional milestones like home ownership. For many of us, travel is a chance to escape our routines, explore new places, and and maybe even find ourselves. But does travel really change us?
Google Fi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不会受到数据流量降速的影响。你是否在憧憬下一次度假？如果是的话，你并不孤单。对于许多美国人来说，旅行越来越被视为一种必需品，而非奢侈品。根据 Investipedia 2025 年的“美国梦研究”，75% 的千禧一代认为年度度假是他们心目中美国梦的关键组成部分，其重要性甚至超过了拥有住房等传统里程碑。对我们许多人来说，旅行是一个逃离日常琐事、探索新地方，甚至可能找回自我的机会。但旅行真的能改变我们吗？
And if so, how? How does encountering unfamiliar environments affect the way we think? Does travel make us happier or improve our well-being? How are technology and social media changing the experience of travel? And if you want to travel but don't have the budget or time, is it possible to gain some of the benefits of travel
如果能，它是如何改变的？接触陌生的环境如何影响我们的思维方式？旅行会让我们更快乐或改善我们的幸福感吗？科技和社交媒体如何改变旅行体验？如果你想旅行但没有预算或时间，是否有可能通过以旅行的心态对待你居住的地方，从而获得旅行的一些益处？
by approaching the place where you live with a travel mindset? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Andrew Stevenson, a senior lecturer in psychology at Manchester Metropolitan University in the UK. He's a cultural psychologist who is interested in the way that space and places affect the way that we feel, think, and act. He is author of the 2023 book, The Psychology of Travel,
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。今天的嘉宾是英国曼彻斯特城市大学心理学高级讲师安德鲁·史蒂文森博士。他是一位文化心理学家，对空间和地点如何影响我们的感受、思维和行为很感兴趣。他是 2023 年出版的《旅行心理学》一书的作者，
and has been quoted widely on the psychology of travel by media outlets, including The Washington Post, the BBC, USA Today, and others. Dr. Stevenson, thank you for joining me today. Hello, and thanks very much for having me. It's a pleasure to be here, and I'm looking forward to having an interesting conversation about psychology and travel. Absolutely. So let's start with a big question.
他的观点被《华盛顿邮报》、英国广播公司 (BBC)、《今日美国》等媒体广泛引用。史蒂文森博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。你好，非常感谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里，我很期待就心理学和旅行进行一场有趣的对话。当然。那么，让我们从一个大问题开始。
A lot of people talk about travel as something that, changes you or broadens your perspective on life. Through the lens of psychology, is that true? Does travel change us? And if it does, how? Well, I think travel is a transformative activity. And it should first perhaps be said that it's not a universal activity because I think even in the United States, only about 50% of the population have passports. But if you think about other nations, maybe nations with less average income, travel is quite a privilege for a few lucky people. But we should think about what we mean by travel, and it doesn't just necessarily mean international travel. Travel can involve going for a walk from one village to another, and I think
很多人说旅行是一件能改变你或拓宽你人生视野的事情。从心理学的角度来看，这是真的吗？旅行会改变我们吗？如果会，它是如何改变的？嗯，我认为旅行是一种变革性的活动。首先也许应该说，这并不是一种普遍的活动，因为我认为即使在美国，也只有大约 50% 的人口拥有护照。但如果你想到其他国家，也许是平均收入较低的国家，旅行对少数幸运儿来说是一种特权。但我们应该思考我们所说的“旅行”是什么意思，它并不一定只意味着国际旅行。旅行可以包括从一个村庄步行到另一个村庄，我认为
any kind of engagement with your environment, whether it's local, national or international, is definitely going to influence you as a person. Let's talk about mental health. health and well-being as aspects of travel. Sometimes you just want to go on a trip to relax and recharge. Do people usually come back from vacations happier, better adjusted than when they left? The relationship between happiness and well-being and travel has been quite well-researched. It's quite a complex relationship, but I think we can broadly say that there are two types of travel mindset that people engage in when they're traveling. One of them is called hedonistic travel or hedonistic well-being, and the other one is named eudamonic
任何与环境的互动，无论是本地的、国家的还是国际的，肯定都会影响你作为一个人的成长。让我们谈谈心理健康和幸福感作为旅行的方面。有时你只是想去旅行以放松和充电。人们通常从度假回来后会比离开时更快乐、适应得更好吗？幸福感、健康与旅行之间的关系已经得到了很好的研究。这是一个相当复杂的关系，但我认为我们可以大致说，人们在旅行时会采取两种类型的旅行心态。一种被称为享乐主义旅行或享乐主义幸福感，另一种被称为“尤达蒙尼克”（eudaimonic）
well-being. Now, in everyday English, hedonistic means pleasure-seeking, doesn't it? So a hedonist is somebody who travels for fun and sun and sea and just basically having a great time. And the other type of well-being, eudamonic, means, roughly speaking, self-improvement, travel to improve yourself and maybe even challenge yourself. And so those are two different types of happiness that many people are chasing. I think, though, it's probably a mistake to pigeonhole people and put them into one or two categories because I think anyone who's traveled probably
幸福感。在日常英语中，享乐主义意味着追求快乐，对吧？所以享乐主义者就是为了乐趣、阳光和大海，基本上就是为了玩得开心而旅行的人。而另一种幸福感，“尤达蒙尼克”，大致意味着自我提升，通过旅行来提升自己，甚至挑战自己。所以这是许多人正在追求的两种不同类型的幸福。不过，我认为把人归入一两个类别可能是一个错误，因为我认为任何旅行过的人可能
knows that on a typical trip, you may have a few hours of hedonistic enjoyment. And then the day after, you might focus on something a little bit more related to self-improvement. Maybe you've on a cookery course in Mexico or visiting an art gallery. So I think we can channel hop between these two types of travel, but they do have different consequences, I think. I think most of us, when we take trips, we're looking for some kind of a boost to our well-being, and we usually feel that.
都知道，在一次典型的旅行中，你可能会有几个小时的享乐主义享受。然后第二天，你可能会专注于一些与自我提升更相关的事情。也许你在墨西哥参加了烹饪课程，或者参观了美术馆。所以我认为我们可以在这两种旅行类型之间切换，但我认为它们确实有不同的后果。我认为我们大多数人在旅行时，都在寻求某种幸福感的提升，而且我们通常能感觉到这一点。
But how long does a boost like that typically last? I always feel once I've gotten on the plane to go home, that somehow the happy gets sucked out of me. Is it just me or does it last longer for most people? I don't think it's just you. I think there is this syndrome called the post-vacation syndrome that people talk about. I was listening to a podcast about this morning actually. But I think there are lots of factors which might influence how much you experience that. There is some research interestingly enough to suggest that the lasting effect of eudamonic travel, i.e. travel for self-improvement, can be a little bit longer than the lasting effect of hedonistic travel. whose effects might evaporate a bit more quickly, but I think we may accept that. The other factor which might influence how long-lasting the effect of travel on us is,
但这种提升通常能持续多久？我总觉得一旦我上了回家的飞机，那种快乐感似乎就从我身上被抽走了。是我一个人这样，还是对大多数人来说它能持续更久？我不认为只有你这样。我认为有一种人们常说的“假期后综合症”。我今天早上还在听一个关于这个的播客。但我认为有很多因素可能会影响你体验到这种感觉的程度。有趣的是，有一些研究表明，“尤达蒙尼克”旅行（即为了自我提升而旅行）的持久影响可能比享乐主义旅行的持久影响稍微长一点，后者的影响可能会蒸发得更快，但我认为我们可能接受这一点。另一个可能影响旅行对我们影响持久性的因素是，
is the so-called discrepancy model, which looks at the perceived gap between how good we expected a trip to be and how good it actually was. some of the best trips or the best vacations are the ones that you didn't have such high expectations of. And I think sometimes we put so much pressure on ourselves and say to ourselves, this is going to be the trip of a lifetime. It's on my bucket list. And those are the ones that can sometimes disappoint us.
所谓的“差异模型”，它着眼于我们预期的旅行质量与实际旅行质量之间的感知差距。一些最好的旅行或最好的假期是你没有抱那么高期望的那些。而且我认为有时我们给自己施加了太大的压力，对自己说，这将是一生难忘的旅行。它在我的愿望清单上。而这些有时会让我们失望。
So I think the discrepancy model has got something to offer us there as well. Now, is there a difference between travel and tourism? I'm glad you asked me that. I've got a lovely quote here from the American novelist Paul Bowles, who wrote a famous novel called The Shelter in Sky about his travels in North Africa at the end of the 20th century. Here he talks about the difference between a traveller and a tourist. He says as follows, whereas a tourist generally hurries back home at the end of a few weeks or months, a traveller belongs no more to one place than to the next, moving slowly over periods of years from one part of the earth. to another. In other words, tourism is usually something which has a kind of boomerang effect. It's a commodity that we buy that involves usually a return ticket. And travel can be something a little bit more open-ended and we're not entirely sure when it's going to end. And it's quite likely that it will last a little bit longer and meander a little bit more. So I think they are different but obviously related.
所以我认为差异模型在这里也为我们提供了一些参考。那么，旅行和旅游之间有区别吗？很高兴你问我这个问题。我这里有一句来自美国小说家保罗·鲍尔斯的美妙引言，他写了一部著名的小说《遮蔽的天空》，讲述了他在 20 世纪末在北非的旅行。在这里，他谈到了旅行者和游客之间的区别。他说：游客通常在几周或几个月后匆忙回家，而旅行者并不属于任何一个地方，他们多年来缓慢地从地球的一个部分移动到另一个部分。换句话说，旅游通常是一种具有某种“回旋镖效应”的东西。它是我们购买的一种商品，通常涉及一张往返票。而旅行可以是一种更开放的东西，我们并不完全确定它何时会结束。而且它很可能会持续更久，也会更随性一些。所以我认为它们是不同的，但显然是相关的。
Travel actually make people more open-minded and less likely to be biased against people who are different, especially those who come from a different culture or who speak another language. That's an interesting question, the question of being open-minded. There is a cliche which says that travel broadens the mind, of course, and that's a bit more complex than it sounds. Going back to the idea of travel and tourism very quickly, The amusing quote about that is that somebody once said that a traveller is what we call ourselves and a tourist is what we call other people.
旅行真的能让人更开明，减少对不同人群的偏见吗，尤其是那些来自不同文化或说另一种语言的人？这是一个有趣的问题，关于“开明”的问题。当然，有一句陈词滥调说“旅行拓宽视野”，这比听起来要复杂得多。快速回到旅行和旅游的想法，关于这个的一个有趣的引言是，有人曾经说，旅行者是我们对自己的称呼，而游客是我们对他人的称呼。
So that kind of amused me a little bit. But going back to the question of travel broadening the mind, clearly I think it does have the potential to do that. But there is a fascinating typology that some social psychologists came up with looking at the different types of travellers or the different types of travellers or the different types of mindsets people have when they travel. Imagine a continuum, okay? And at one end, you've got, let's call it package tourism for the lack of a better phrase. So these are trips which are extremely popular. This is a mode of travel where we often visit geographically different places,
所以这让我觉得有点好笑。但回到旅行拓宽视野的问题，显然我认为它确实有这种潜力。但社会心理学家提出了一种迷人的类型学，观察不同类型的旅行者，或者人们旅行时拥有的不同心态。想象一个连续体，好吗？在一端，我们称之为“跟团旅游”（为了缺乏更好的词汇）。所以这些是非常受欢迎的旅行。这是一种我们经常访问地理上不同的地方的旅行模式，
but within a bubble of companions from the same culture as us. And we often are accompanied everywhere by a tour guide and so we don't get into too many intrepid adventures or scrap. So that you might want to call that conservative travel. At the other end of this continuum, you've got what you might call the explorers or belonging seekers who typically travel independently and are a lot more likely to, for example, visit the houses or domestic scenes of the people in the towns and cities where they're visiting, if you're a conservative travel or a dependent, you're going to really only investigate the hotels and the tourist spots. Now, of course, the missing link to this argument
但在来自同一文化的同伴的保护伞下。我们经常有导游陪同，所以我们不会进行太多大胆的冒险或冲突。所以你可能想称之为“保守型旅行”。在这个连续体的另一端，有你可能称之为“探险家”或“归属感寻求者”的人，他们通常独立旅行，更有可能，例如，访问他们正在访问的城镇和城市中人们的房屋或家庭场景，如果你是一个保守型旅行者或依赖型旅行者，你真的只会调查酒店和旅游景点。现在，当然，这个论点的缺失环节
is that I think the conservative travel is less likely to broaden the mind, but you might regard it as being quite a lot safer because some people might feel a bit more vulnerable when they're travelling. So it's not a criticism of that mode of travel. And there's no coincidence that it is very popular because people do want to feel safe. And especially since COVID a few years ago, I think there has been a reemergence of the kind of travel in bubbles and the conservative travel, because for a while or so, we weren't able to travel at all. I wrote this book, The Psychology of Travel, ironically, during the two years where I wasn't able to travel at all. It was kind of something to do. I think most of us would agree that travel can be stressful.
是我认为保守型旅行不太可能拓宽视野，但你可能会认为它相当安全，因为有些人旅行时可能会感到有点脆弱。所以这不是对那种旅行模式的批评。而且它非常受欢迎并非巧合，因为人们确实想感到安全。尤其是几年前新冠疫情以来，我认为在泡泡中旅行和保守型旅行又重新出现了，因为有一段时间我们根本无法旅行。我写这本书《旅行心理学》，讽刺的是，是在我根本无法旅行的那两年里写的。这算是一种消遣。我想我们大多数人都会同意旅行可能是压力很大的。
I find that when I think back on a trip, some of my best stories are about the mistakes, like the time my ex booked us to the wrong country or the aggravations, like once I missed a connecting flight in Venezuela, but then I found somebody who volunteered to drive us to our destination. Is it common to focus on the challenges of travel? And am I weird in focusing on the mixups rather than the positive experiences of a given trip? Well, historically there was a concept called travel fever. And travel fever is kind of an umbrella term for all the fears, anxieties and worries that travel can produce in us. I think quite a lot of domestic arguments revolve around holidays. And it's ironic because that's kind of the thing that you do to enjoy yourself. But psychologists have distinguished between travel anxiety, travel fear and travel worry. We can leave aside phobias because that's an irrational sort of discrete category of experience on its own. Well, let's just think about the other three.
我发现当我回想一次旅行时，我最好的一些故事是关于错误的，比如我的前任把我们订到了错误的国家，或者是一些烦恼，比如有一次我在委内瑞拉错过了转机航班，但我后来找到了一个自愿开车送我们去目的地的人。专注于旅行的挑战很常见吗？我专注于混乱而不是特定旅行的积极体验，这很奇怪吗？嗯，历史上有一个概念叫“旅行热”。“旅行热”是旅行能带给我们的所有恐惧、焦虑和担忧的总称。我认为很多家庭争吵都围绕着假期。这很讽刺，因为那是你为了享受自己而做的事情。但心理学家区分了旅行焦虑、旅行恐惧和旅行担忧。我们可以撇开恐惧症不谈，因为那是一种非理性的、独立的体验类别。嗯，让我们只考虑其他三个。
Fear of travel is usually something which is leveled at specific experiences, particular things we're worried about. Now, that might be something like flying or it might be something like tasting food that you're not familiar with. Sometimes it's just fear of the unknown. The second one, anxiety, is a kind of undefinable feeling of just feeling unsettled when you're in a new situation. Also, that's something that you can experience. But the third one, worry about travel, can actually be quite valuable. Because if you think about it, there is quite a lot to organise when you go travelling. And it's pretty valuable and useful to worry about making sure that you book the tickets on the right.
旅行恐惧通常是针对特定体验的，是我们担心的特定事情。那可能是像飞行这样的事情，或者可能是品尝你不熟悉的食物。有时只是对未知的恐惧。第二个，焦虑，是一种当你处于新环境中时感到不安的、无法定义的感受。这也是你可以体验到的。但第三个，对旅行的担忧，实际上可能非常有价值。因为如果你想一想，当你去旅行时有很多事情需要组织。担心确保你在正确的日子预订机票，或者携带正确的物品，或者你没有在错误的地方携带尖锐物体，这是非常有价值和有用的。
day or carrying the right belongings with you or you're not carrying sharp objects in the wrong places. So I think a little bit of travel anxiety or travel worry is not such a bad thing. And these kind of things can be mediated or prepared for just with a bit of extra preparation and planning, I think. Things can go wrong at every step of a journey, can't they? You can have anxiety before you set off. You can have anxiety while you're traveling and you can have anxiety once you've returned if you've lost some of your belongings. But all of these things can be moderated with a bit more planning and perhaps a little bit of mindfulness, which is something we can perhaps talk about a little bit later on. What about these people who are afraid to travel but maybe they want to?
所以我认为一点点旅行焦虑或旅行担忧并不是坏事。我认为这些事情可以通过一点额外的准备和计划来调节或预防。旅程的每一步都可能出错，不是吗？你可以在出发前感到焦虑，你可以在旅行时感到焦虑，如果你丢失了一些物品，你可以在回来后感到焦虑。但所有这些事情都可以通过更多的计划和也许一点点正念来调节，这可能是我们稍后可以谈论的事情。那些害怕旅行但可能想去旅行的人呢？
I mean, are there things that you can do to sort of prepare yourself to travel if you have that fear or anxiety? I think so, yeah. I mean, going back to this idea of conservative travel, and I think travel, it's understandable that people do worry about it, because most of the time our lives are quite routine and we take ourselves outside the routine of our day-to-day life, and it can be quite anxiety-provoking. And so I think the advice to try to reduce anxiety a little bit is to maybe just think about traveling incrementally, maybe with people who are a little bit more experienced, first of all. Also maybe think about traveling at first, the places that have got some similarities with the places that you already know about. It's basically about learning a new skill, isn't it?
我的意思是，如果你有那种恐惧或焦虑，有什么事情可以做来让自己准备好去旅行吗？我想是的，是的。我的意思是，回到这个“保守型旅行”的想法，我认为人们担心旅行是可以理解的，因为大多数时候我们的生活相当规律，而我们把自己带出了日常生活的常规，这可能会引起相当大的焦虑。所以我认为减少一点焦虑的建议是，也许只是考虑循序渐进地旅行，也许首先和那些更有经验的人一起。也可能考虑首先去那些和你已经了解的地方有一些相似之处的地方。这基本上是在学习一项新技能，不是吗？
When we try to learn a new skill or get to know a new person, we go into it on tiptoes at first, rather than jumping in with two feet. And I think that's one thing that can reduce anxiety by, first of all, trying familiar-type trips, maybe try and package holidays, first of all, traveling with people we know. And the third thing, and I mentioned it before, is just engaging in a little bit more planning and research before you set off. We have the luxury these days, I've been able to plan ahead, you know, and it's quite difficult these days to, in fact, visit something or a place, which is a complete mystery because pretty much everywhere is documented, isn't it?
当我们试图学习一项新技能或结识一个新朋友时，我们起初是踮着脚尖进入的，而不是直接跳进去。我认为这是一件可以减少焦虑的事情，首先尝试熟悉的旅行，也许首先尝试跟团度假，和我们认识的人一起旅行。第三件事，我之前提到过，就是在出发前多做一点计划和研究。我们现在有提前计划的奢侈，你知道，而且现在很难去访问一个完全神秘的东西或地方，因为几乎到处都有记录，不是吗？
You're sort of alluding to the technologies that enable us to plan out our trips, and we can now navigate almost around the world using Google Maps on our phones rather than getting lost all the time. How have these technologies change the experience of travel, and is it all for the better? Well, I can remember the first experience I had of traveling in, which to me was quite an exotic trip when I went over to Malaysia with my bicycle in 1999, cycled across the mainland. And I came across these things called internet cafes.
你是在暗示那些使我们能够规划行程的技术，我们现在可以使用手机上的谷歌地图在世界各地导航，而不是一直迷路。这些技术如何改变了旅行体验，而且这一切都是为了更好吗？嗯，我记得我第一次旅行的经历，对我来说那是一次相当异国情调的旅行，1999 年我带着自行车去了马来西亚，骑行穿过大陆。我偶然发现了这些叫“网吧”的东西。
I know these are sort of obviously on the, they're dwindling at the moment. But I thought this was a fascinating place to observe people because you had people from lots of different countries who were in Southeast Asia spending quite a lot of their time in front of screens communicating to people back home. not really experiencing a village life in Malaysia or whatever. So I think we have to think about the role of technology in travel.
我知道这些东西显然目前正在减少。但我认为这是一个观察人们的迷人地方，因为你有来自许多不同国家的人在东南亚，他们花了很多时间在屏幕前与家里的人交流，并没有真正体验马来西亚的乡村生活之类的。所以我认为我们必须思考技术在旅行中的作用。
Nowadays, of course, as you say, it's all its GPS and its mobile phones. There has been some research done about the different experiences that people have when discovering a new place either by using their mobile phone to navigate or by asking people the way. Do you remember when we used to do that? And it was quite interesting because the people who had asked people the way and weren't allowed to use their mobile phones in this particular study, they, when they were later tested asked questions about what they remembered about the streets and the places and some
如今，当然，正如你所说，全是 GPS 和手机。已经有一些研究探讨了人们在发现一个新地方时，通过使用手机导航或问路所获得的不同体验。你还记得我们过去常那样做吗？这非常有趣，因为那些问路并且不被允许使用手机的人，当他们后来被测试问及他们对街道和地方的记忆，以及一些
of the sensory experiences, they gave much more detailed answers than did the people who had kind of worked it out for themselves with their phone. So, I mean, I'm not a person who is a ludite who thinks that mobile phones are a bad idea, but does change the experience. And maybe there is some value in trying to re-emerse ourselves in some of the social connectedness, face-to-face social connectedness that we used to have to do, I suppose. Just one more interesting thing about travel and technology that's a recent development in the last few years is the rise of what's sometimes known as digital nomadism. which is a fascinating sort of new category of work, life, travel, balance, isn't it? On a recent trip I had, which was for work in Central America,
感官体验时，他们给出的答案比那些用手机自己解决问题的人详细得多。所以，我的意思是，我不是一个认为手机是坏主意的卢德分子，但这确实改变了体验。也许重新沉浸在我们过去必须做的社交联系、面对面的社交联系中是有价值的。关于旅行和技术的另一件有趣的事情是过去几年出现的一个新发展，即有时被称为“数字游民”的兴起，这是一种迷人的工作、生活、旅行平衡的新类别，不是吗？在我最近的一次工作旅行中，在美洲中部，
I stayed in an apartment block, and I noticed that quite a lot of the people staying there will get up in the morning and basically carry out their ordinary office jobs at these different individual tables, working in lots of random different IT related professions and then every two or three days they would do a bit of travelling. So what they were doing was really challenging the idea of workspace, travel and home space.
我住在一个公寓楼里，我注意到很多住在那儿的人早上起来，基本上在这些不同的独立桌子上处理他们普通的办公室工作，从事许多随机的、与 IT 相关的不同职业，然后每两三天他们就会去旅行一下。所以他们真正挑战的是工作空间、旅行和家庭空间的概念。
And they were making a living by virtue of the fact that they had their laptop with them. So digital nomadism for those people who are lucky enough to be able to work through their laptops, is a whole new formulation of the way that we can now travel work at the same time. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk to Dr. Stevenson about how the pressure to document and share our travel experiences on social media is changing the way we experience travel. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot.
他们凭借随身携带笔记本电脑这一事实谋生。所以对于那些幸运到能够通过笔记本电脑工作的人来说，数字游民是我们现在可以同时旅行和工作的一种全新的方式。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与史蒂文森博士讨论在社交媒体上记录和分享旅行体验的压力如何改变我们体验旅行的方式。你的夏天从家得宝 (The Home Depot) 的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。
It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas. grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price invalid May 14th or May 27, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet.
是时候用 Next Grill 四头燃气烧烤炉开启夏季户外烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装来招待客人，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝获得低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请见 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步。
How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app
我们省了多少钱？足够了。足够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。离水边只有几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订
and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Related to the technology issue, a few years ago, I spent three days in Nice, hiking the Inca Trail to get to Mocetrail to get to Mocetra. Pichu, which was an amazing experience. When I got to the ruins, I was stunned by all the daytrippers
并节省高达 20%，获得你预期的住宿体验。当你想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时。你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了住宿。关于技术问题，几年前，我在秘鲁花了三天时间徒步印加古道前往马丘比丘，那是一次令人惊叹的体验。当我到达遗址时，我被所有的短途游客惊呆了，
who spent virtually all their time they're taking selfies rather than just experiencing being in the place. And that kind of took away from my enjoyment too. Do you think that the pressure to document and share our travel experiences on social media is changing the way we experience travel, both in real time and then how we remember the trips. Yes, two different questions there. Both of them really interesting. First of all, I think that the way that we document everyday experience using the selfies, for example,
他们几乎把所有时间都花在自拍上，而不是仅仅体验身处那个地方的感觉。这在某种程度上也削弱了我的享受。你认为在社交媒体上记录和分享旅行体验的压力是否正在改变我们体验旅行的方式，无论是在实时中，还是在我们如何记忆这些旅行时？是的，那里有两个不同的问题。它们都非常有趣。首先，我认为我们记录日常体验的方式，例如使用自拍，
has changed the way we experience all of our movements and mobility, and it doesn't just apply to travel. So I think what you'll see nowadays is people at the gym, at concerts and on holiday, communicating their experiences by taking photographs in which they are in the foreground and whatever it is their experience is in the background. Now it depends how you want to look at that. If it was being optimistic, you could say, well, this is great because it shows that people are able to share their experiences and immerse themselves in those experiences.
已经改变了我们体验所有移动和流动性的方式，这不仅仅适用于旅行。所以我认为你现在看到的是人们在健身房、音乐会和度假时，通过拍摄照片来交流他们的体验，照片中他们处于前景，而他们正在体验的任何东西都在背景中。现在这取决于你想如何看待它。如果你是乐观的，你可以说，嗯，这太棒了，因为它表明人们能够分享他们的体验并沉浸在这些体验中。
and the technology allows them to form this kind of imagined community with their followers and friends. So that's a good thing. I guess the style of photography has changed because, of course, the skill of taking a photograph of a place has perhaps been replaced
技术允许他们与追随者和朋友形成这种想象的社区。所以这是一件好事。我想摄影的风格已经改变了，因为当然，拍摄一个地方的照片的技巧也许已经被
by the desire to show yourself in that place. And that's a very different kind of perspective, isn't it? But I think on the positive side, we do use photography as a form of selective memory, don't we? These days, I'm getting a little bit older. I do take photographs of things just to help me remember them,
想要在那个地方展示自己的愿望所取代。那是一种非常不同的视角，不是吗？但我认为在积极的一面，我们确实把摄影作为一种选择性记忆的形式，不是吗？这些天，我年纪大了。我确实会拍一些东西的照片，只是为了帮助我记住它们，
but I think that's always been a pretty good idea. I guess you could also say about photography is that it's a kind of unreliable witness, isn't it, of the things that we have experienced. Maybe we need that. We tend not to take the photographs of the arguments we're having or the cues that we're standing in during our trip, but we take more photographs about the things where we might call them peak experiences. I don't think cameras were ever a reliable historical document, but I just think the way that we
但我认为这一直是个不错的主意。我想你也可以说摄影是一种不可靠的证人，不是吗，关于我们所经历的事情。也许我们需要那个。我们倾向于不拍摄我们在旅行中发生的争吵或排队的照片，但我们拍摄更多关于我们可能称之为“巅峰体验”的事情的照片。我不认为相机曾经是可靠的历史文件，但我只是认为我们
place ourselves in those experiences has changed a little bit as well. In your book, you write about how other people are travel companions and the people we meet while we're traveling are an essential part of the experience and that there's really no such thing as a solo trip. Can you talk about that? This was something that occurred to me when I was writing the book, actually, but the idea of solo travel. It's almost a bit of a myth. I mean, you can travel without your friends and without your family, but it's very difficult to travel without other people unless you're, I was going to say, unless you're climbing Everest, but recent photographs suggest that
将自己置于这些体验中的方式也发生了一点变化。在你的书中，你写到其他人是旅行同伴，我们在旅行中遇到的人是体验的重要组成部分，而且实际上没有所谓的“独自旅行”。你能谈谈这个吗？这实际上是我在写书时想到的，但关于独自旅行的想法。这几乎是一个神话。我的意思是，你可以没有朋友和家人去旅行，但很难不和别人一起旅行，除非你，我本来想说，除非你在攀登珠穆朗玛峰，但最近的照片表明
Everest got quite a long queue, quite a long queue up there now. But I think one of the theories that psychologists always talk about is the theory of planned behaviour, the idea that we plan to do something and then we do it and that we're very logical using very logical cognition. But actually, a lot of our decisions are complicated by other people. And I think anyone who's a member of a family or a group of friends knows that the things you want to do in your lives, and this includes travel, are often diluted or influenced by what everybody else is doing. This can be as simple as looking through the window of a restaurant and seeing that it's empty
珠穆朗玛峰现在排队排得很长，排得很长。但我认为心理学家总是谈论的理论之一是“计划行为理论”，即我们计划做某事，然后我们去做，而且我们非常合乎逻辑，使用非常合乎逻辑的认知。但实际上，我们的许多决定都被其他人复杂化了。而且我认为任何作为家庭或朋友团体成员的人都知道，你在生活中想做的事情，包括旅行，往往会被其他人正在做的事情所稀释或影响。这可以简单到透过餐厅的窗户看到里面是空的，
and suddenly deciding it might not be the place you want to eat because nobody else is eating there. So social influence has a big effect on us, but also social influence is likely to increase the likelihood of our doing something, especially as you were talking earlier about people who might be a bit nervous about visiting somewhere different. And if you see people who you think might be like-minded in a place, then that does have, it might prompt you to share some of those experiences. But there is another side to sort of social aspects of travel. And I think this is quite important and interesting in that I think it's got a relationship to the idea of prejudice and discrimination as well. because obviously in the era of the kind of cultural wars and us trying to learn a bit more about different types of people
然后突然决定它可能不是你想吃饭的地方，因为没有别人在那里吃饭。所以社会影响对我们有很大的影响，但社会影响也可能增加我们做某事的可能性，特别是正如你刚才谈到的那些可能对去不同地方感到紧张的人。如果你看到你认为志同道合的人在一个地方，那么这确实有，它可能会促使你分享一些这些体验。但旅行的社会方面还有另一面。而且我认为这非常重要和有趣，因为我认为它与偏见和歧视的想法也有关系。因为显然在文化战争的时代，我们试图更多地了解不同类型的人，
and there is this fear of difference out there, there is a theory which suggests that when you travel to a new country, which might be a new country to you, let's say you took a holiday in Nigeria or Mexico or something like that, being in that country might influence your attitude towards Mexicans and Nigerians. And there is the theory in psychology called the contact hypothesis, which basically says, you've heard people say things like,
而且外面存在对差异的恐惧，有一种理论认为，当你去一个新国家旅行时，那对你来说可能是一个新国家，假设你在尼日利亚或墨西哥度假之类的，身处那个国家可能会影响你对墨西哥人和尼日利亚人的态度。心理学中有一种理论叫“接触假说”，它基本上说，你听过人们说这样的话，
well, actually, when you get to know them, they're quite nice. And this whole idea that once you have contact with a group of people who previously you might be skeptical about, maybe based on what you'd read in the newspapers, some of that evaporates when you meet them face to face. But there's a lovely complication to this theory. One piece of research suggested or demonstrated actually that prejudice reduces when you meet people who are different from you only when you meet them on an equal status situation. So what I mean by that is if you meet lots of people from Nigeria, but those people from Nigeria are cleaners or people who are serving you drinks or people who are working for.
嗯，实际上，当你了解他们时，他们相当不错。这种想法是，一旦你与一群你以前可能持怀疑态度的人接触，也许是基于你在报纸上读到的内容，当你面对面见到他们时，其中一些怀疑就会消失。但这个理论有一个可爱的复杂性。一项研究表明，实际上，只有当你与地位平等的人接触时，偏见才会减少。所以我的意思是，如果你遇到很多尼日利亚人，但那些尼日利亚人是清洁工，或者是为你端饮料的人，或者是为你工作的人，
you in some way, that prejudice is not likely to be challenged. However, if you meet those people and a social situation in their houses as colleagues and equals, then it's at those situations where prejudice can be reduced by travel. So that's another nice example of travel broadening in the mind and making you a bit more cosmopolitans, a good word, isn't it? Yeah. Speaking of other people, I mean, I've done a fair amount of traveling in my life and I'm pretty sure I have some close friends. I could never travel with, and I'm not going to say who they are. But how do you know if someone is going to be a good travel companion? What are the characteristics you should look for?
以某种方式，这种偏见不太可能受到挑战。然而，如果你在社交场合、在他们的家里、作为同事和平等的人见到这些人，那么在这些情况下，旅行可以减少偏见。所以这是旅行拓宽视野并让你变得有点“世界主义”（这是一个好词，不是吗？）的另一个很好的例子。是的。说到其他人，我的意思是，我一生中旅行过不少，我很确定我有几个亲密的朋友。我永远无法和他们一起旅行，我不会说他们是谁。但你怎么知道某人是否会成为一个好的旅行同伴？你应该寻找哪些特征？
I think I might have to answer this from my own experience. It wasn't something that I wrote a lot about in the book, and I don't want to step out of my comfort zone. But I'm quite antisocial. You know, I personally, I find the two people who I enjoy traveling with most are myself or my partner. And I've got lots of people who I like to spend time with, but it is quite difficult to spend a prolonged period with that person. But I would say that the best way to make a social travel trip a success is to ensure that you and that other person or those other people are doing something together that you really enjoy.
我想我可能得从我自己的经验来回答这个问题。这不是我在书中写了很多的东西，我不想走出我的舒适区。但我相当反社会。你知道，我个人，我发现我最喜欢一起旅行的两个人是我自己或我的伴侣。我有很多我喜欢花时间在一起的人，但与那个人度过一段漫长的时间是相当困难的。但我会说，让社交旅行取得成功的最好方法是确保你和那个人或那些人正在一起做一些你们真正喜欢的事情。
For example, if you're going on a skiing trip with some people, then the great thing about that, is, even if you don't get on with them 100%, you're all sharing an experience together. And I think that can be a really good advantage. Doing something together, it can be a great replacement for not having lots and lots of things in common generally. And I mean that in the most positive way. I mean, the flip side of that is you can travel with people who you have lots in common with, but you don't actually do anything together, and that kind of wouldn't work as well.
例如，如果你和一些人去滑雪旅行，那么那件事的好处是，即使你和他们相处得不是 100% 好，你们都在一起分享一种体验。而且我认为这可能是一个非常好的优势。一起做某事，它可以很好地替代通常没有很多共同点。我的意思是最积极的。我的意思是，反面是你可以和有很多共同点的人一起旅行，但你们实际上并没有一起做任何事情，那样的效果就不会那么好。
There's a concept in psychology called flow. It's related to well-being, and it's also related to mindfulness. And basically it's the idea that just like an artist who's painting a picture, it gets totally lost in the task, if you're traveling in a way where you experience travel flow in a positive way, you're being totally absorbed in the task that you're doing, and you almost lose awareness of where you are and what time it is. And that kind of idea of doing nice things together that you're really enjoying.
心理学中有一个概念叫“心流”。它与幸福感有关，也与正念有关。基本上，这就像一个正在画画的艺术家，完全沉浸在任务中，如果你以一种积极的方式体验旅行心流，你就会完全沉浸在你正在做的事情中，你几乎失去了对你在哪里以及现在几点的意识。那种一起做你们真正喜欢的愉快事情的想法。
Skiing, whitewater rafting, there's been some research done on that, even walking. I think the key is have something to do which brings you together. How did you become interested in the psychology of travel? And what was the impetus for writing the book? I was surprised that this book hadn't already been written. I couldn't believe it. I mean, we're way beyond the era of popular tourism now. If you search academic journals, as I do now and again, you will find that there is quite a lot of research that has been conducted on topics related to travel and psychology.
滑雪、白水漂流，已经有一些关于这方面的研究，甚至走路。我认为关键是要有一些能把你们聚在一起的事情。你是怎么对旅行心理学产生兴趣的？写这本书的动力是什么？我很惊讶这本书还没有被写出来。我简直不敢相信。我的意思是，我们现在已经远远超出了大众旅游的时代。如果你像我偶尔做的那样搜索学术期刊，你会发现已经进行了很多关于与旅行和心理学相关主题的研究。
And a lot of these relate to the questions you've been asking today, Kim. However, I was also mindful of the fact that nobody seemed to have sat down and collected all these things together and written them in a more accessible way, dare I say it. Now, I'm as guilty as anyone else of writing academic articles that most people will never read, okay, because they get published in journals and they may get read by other academics, which is great. But I thought it would be a nice idea to divide up the psychology of travel into five or six topics. And you've covered a lot of those today, social travel, health and travel, fear of travel. and to just cherry pick some of the most interesting findings from other researchers and make these into a sort of slimmer volume which travellers or people with an interest in travel would like to read about, not just academics. So there was that. And then the second factor was, as I mentioned before, there was 18 months where we just couldn't travel and needed something to do.
其中很多都与你今天问的问题有关，金。然而，我也意识到没有人似乎坐下来把所有这些东西收集在一起，并以一种更易于理解的方式写出来，我敢说。现在，我和任何其他人一样，写了一些大多数人永远不会读的学术文章，好吗，因为它们发表在期刊上，可能会被其他学者阅读，这很棒。但我认为把旅行心理学分成五六个主题是个好主意。你今天涵盖了很多，社交旅行、健康与旅行、旅行恐惧。并挑选其他研究人员的一些最有趣的发现，把这些变成一种旅行者或对旅行感兴趣的人想读的更薄的卷，而不仅仅是学者。所以有那个。然后第二个因素是，正如我之前提到的，有 18 个月我们根本无法旅行，需要做点什么。
And this seemed to be almost like a bit of substitute sublimated travel, as Freud might call it. Speaking of substitute travel, another question I think I alluded to this in my introduction was, if you don't have the time with a budget to travel, can you gain some of the benefits of travel by approaching your life and where you live with a travel mindset or maybe reading about other people's travels or even watching videos about travel? I think definitely you can do that. And in fact, there is a school of psychology, which is kind of a mixture between literature, travel, and geography.
这看起来几乎就像是一种替代的、升华的旅行，正如弗洛伊德可能称之为的那样。说到替代旅行，另一个问题，我想我在介绍中提到了这一点，如果你没有时间或预算去旅行，你可以通过以旅行的心态对待你的生活和你居住的地方，或者也许阅读关于别人的旅行，甚至观看关于旅行的视频来获得旅行的一些好处吗？我认为你绝对可以做到这一点。事实上，有一个心理学流派，它是文学、旅行和地理的混合体。
And it's called psychogeography. And it's a little bit of an outlier in the psychology of travel. But psychogeography began in France, in Paris, actually, in the 20th century by a literary artist called Guy de Bourne. He talked a lot about the fact that travel is something that we can, it's a mindset that we can adopt and we don't have to be a long way away from home to behave like a traveler. The most interesting things of the world are not necessarily the ones that are furthest away. And I think we all learned during the pandemic that, I don't know about you,
它被称为“心理地理学”。它是旅行心理学中的一个异类。但心理地理学始于法国，实际上是 20 世纪的巴黎，由一位名叫盖伊·德波的文学艺术家发起。他谈了很多关于旅行是我们能够，这是一种我们可以采取的心态，我们不必离家很远就能像旅行者一样行事。世界上最有趣的事情不一定是离我们最远的事情。而且我认为我们在大流行期间都学到了，我不知道你怎么样，
but I suddenly discovered lots of interesting things about my own, my own area, town village where I lived because we had to walk around and take our fresh air an hour a day. Psychogeography really teaches us that, to take a quote from another psychologist, destinations are not the only places. In other words, we can find interesting things at every point along a journey, not just at the place we're meant to be traveling to. and a nice little prank that some psycho geographers have done is to do exactly what you've just suggested there, Kim, is to maybe take an out-of-date guidebook of their own town and go and check into a hotel in their own city and try to live like a tourist for a long weekend and just see if you can re, I'd like to use the word defamiliarize yourself with your city by looking at it from
但我突然发现关于我居住的地区、城镇和村庄有很多有趣的事情，因为我们每天必须走出去呼吸一小时新鲜空气。心理地理学确实教会了我们这一点，引用另一位心理学家的话说，目的地并不是唯一的地方。换句话说，我们可以在旅途中的每一个点发现有趣的事物，而不仅仅是在我们打算前往的地方。一些心理地理学家做过一个有趣的小恶作剧，正如你刚才建议的那样，金，也许是拿一本自己城镇的过时指南，去自己城市的酒店登记入住，试着像游客一样度过一个长周末，看看你是否能重新——我想用“陌生化”这个词——通过从外部观察来重新审视你的城市。
the outside. Now, I'll tell you a little anecdote from when I did my PhD in 2013. My topic for my dissertation, for my PhD, was the experience of arriving in a new place and how that feels. And I did mobile interviews, walking interviews, with six different migrants who had all arrived in Manchester at the same time from different places. And my job basically during this project was to follow them around and ask them questions about how they got to know this city, using different activities like walking, photography, shopping, eating. And it was great because I got to know my own city through the eyes and ears of people who just arrived. And I think I wrote in my PhD that I was basically defamiliarized with my own city.
现在，我讲一个我在2013年攻读博士学位时的小轶事。我博士论文的主题是到达一个新地方的体验以及那种感觉。我对六位来自不同地方、同时到达曼彻斯特的移民进行了移动访谈和步行访谈。在这个项目中，我的工作基本上是跟随他们，询问他们如何通过步行、摄影、购物、饮食等不同活动来了解这座城市。这太棒了，因为我通过刚到达这里的人的眼睛和耳朵了解了我自己的城市。我想我在博士论文中写道，我基本上对自己居住的城市产生了“陌生感”。
And I began to see it as an outsider. That was a fantastic experience. So, yes, I think the short answer to your question is, yes, we can try to take a fresh perspective on our own city, maybe by getting to know it with someone else who's just arrived. So just to wrap up, did the research you did for this book change the way you approach travel in your own life and are you a big travel yourself? I have been a big travel myself, fortunately. I think this is ironic really,
我开始以局外人的眼光看待它。那是一次美妙的经历。所以，是的，我认为对你问题的简短回答是，是的，我们可以尝试以全新的视角看待我们自己的城市，也许可以通过与刚到这里的人一起了解它。那么总结一下，你为这本书所做的研究是否改变了你生活中对待旅行的方式？你自己是一个经常旅行的人吗？幸运的是，我曾经是一个经常旅行的人。我认为这真的很讽刺，
but I think over the last few years I've kind of become a little bit more content with exploring places where I live and maybe by savoring some of the journeys that I have maybe a little bit more. I think I may travel with greater quality but not quite as frequently. And I think at times of sort of eco-referral
但我认为在过去几年里，我变得更满足于探索我居住的地方，也许更多地去品味我所经历的一些旅程。我想我的旅行质量可能更高了，但频率没那么高了。我认为在某种生态焦虑和气候变化的时代，
anxiety and climate change, some of the most meaningful or a meaningful way of making journeys is maybe to take fewer flights, but maybe to go to places where you fly to and stay there a little bit longer and immerse yourselves in those places a little bit more. So I think that's one thing I've tried to do it a little bit more is travel less frequently, but if I can, spend a little longer and try to immerse myself a little bit more in those places. Got any trips planned right now? We're off to Wales for the weekend, which isn't very far from here, but we're going to do a nice walking holiday.
进行旅程最有意义的方式之一也许是减少飞行次数，但如果要去某个地方，就待得久一点，让自己更多地沉浸在那些地方。所以我认为我尝试多做的一件事就是减少旅行频率，但如果可以的话，待的时间长一点，尝试让自己更多地沉浸在那些地方。现在有计划去旅行吗？我们周末要去威尔士，离这里不远，但我们要去度过一个愉快的徒步假期。
Yes, so that's going to be our next trip. So that'll be lovely. Nice. Well, Dr. Stevenson, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been a lot of fun. Thank you so much for having me. And good luck with the rest of the podcast. And that's been a fantastic conversation.
是的，那将是我们的下一次旅行。那会很棒。很好。史蒂文森博士，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。这非常有趣。非常感谢你的邀请。祝你的播客后续节目顺利。这是一次非常棒的谈话。
Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website, at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening.
谢谢。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。感谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Did you know if your windows are bare, indoor temperatures can go up 20 degrees? Get ahead of summer with custom window treatments like solar roller shades from blinds.com and save up to 45% off during the Memorial Day Early Access sale. Whether you want to DIY it or have a pro handle everything, we've got you. Free samples, real design experts, and zero pressure. Just help when you need it. Shop up to 45% off site wide right now during the Early Access Memorial Day sale at blinds.com.
我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。你知道吗，如果你的窗户没有遮挡，室内温度可能会升高20度？通过 blinds.com 的定制窗饰（如太阳能卷帘）提前为夏天做好准备，并在阵亡将士纪念日提前抢购期间享受高达45%的折扣。无论你是想自己动手还是让专业人士处理一切，我们都能满足你。免费样品，真正的设计专家，零压力。当你需要时，我们随时提供帮助。现在就在 blinds.com 的阵亡将士纪念日提前抢购活动中享受全场高达45%的折扣。
Rules and restrictions apply. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
规则和限制适用。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。